was ist glück wie wird das leben zum
erfolg und warum vertuschen
erfolgsmenschen wie dominique strauss
kahn ihr lebensglück in dem sie sich wie
eine wildsau verhalten diese fragen
werden wir heute beantworten
vielleicht über glücks fragen und über
das gelingende leben schreiben die
philosophen ja seit jahrtausenden
gewichtige bücher dass sich die regal
balken biegen
aber der freundliche herr de als gast
bei mir hier im studio in bern sitzt
gilt als forschungs genie das mit einem
buchstäblich zuckersüßen test empirisch
licht in die gesalzenen lebens rätsel
gebracht hat professor mich schon ich
wage es hier als blutiger laie mit ihnen
einem weltweit gefeierten star
psychologe psycho test schnell zu machen
aber der pest ist ja von ihnen
wir haben recherchiert dass sie bluten
freien schokolade kuchen kaum
widerstehen können und sie haben jetzt
die wahl entweder ein küchlein jetzt
gleich oder zwei in der mitte da sind j
ich werde die 2 später schwer weil sie
wissen dass man dann aus kläger geld
oder ich weiß das habe ich möchte lieber
die zwei später haben ja okay also das
ist ja wie komme ich in der mitte das
darauf zurück einem menschen sagen zwei
küchlein jetzt eines jetzt sogar zwei
später was soll das uns über einen
menschen beibringen
ich glaube das kann uns sehr viel sagen
aber ich möchte jetzt lieber deutsch
sprechen nur für die persönlichen
zeitungsmarktes jahr in santos fasst
deutsch und so wie war ihre frage was
soll uns das beibringen über einen
menschen oder jetzt ein küche oder in 20
minuten zwei welt und sehr viel
denn die wahl zwischen mehr später und
weniger jetzt stellt sich als best größe
heraus die bei neurologen als handlungs
kontrolle oder handlungs funktion
bekannt ist
ich habe ein zeitlich aufgeschoben das
ziel im kopf ich will später beide haben
und bin gleichzeitig fähig dem impuls zu
widerstehen es wäre so köstlich gleich
jetzt ich kann es schon riechen schon
sehen
diese impulse unterdrücke ich und setze
meine aufmerksamkeit und meine
einbildungskraft ein um das fernere ziel
weiter zu verfolgen indem ich hier
sitzen bleibe und abfahrt
es geht um selbstkontrolle und ihre
forschung seit 50 jahren sagt der welt
wer sich besser kontrollieren kann wird
mehr erfolg haben im leben wird weniger
einer scheidung ausgesetzt sein wird
gesünder leben all das für die leute ist
weltweit bekannt das experiment aber für
die leute die es noch nicht kennen
wissen ja zählen sie haben das mit
kindern gemacht vor 50 jahren in
stanford und nicht mit schokoküssen das
ist meine recherche dass sie am liebsten
showküche sondern mit marshmallows wie
ich will sie nicht beleidigen aber es
ist ja ein simples experiment also 1 1
ein tolles experiment aber verglichen
mit dem teilchenbeschleuniger am cern in
genf
und sie sind weltberühmt damit geworden
haben sie selber gestand dass das so ein
welterfolg wurde dieses mal auf experten
ja aber es war marshmallow experiment
aber meistens haben wir gar keine
marshmallows vorgesetzt wir verwendeten
was immer das kind wirklich wollte und
wir benutzten sicher nicht diese
gigantischen dinger da die marshmallows
waren diese kleine aber nicht so große
nur winzige
jaja ende sogar dieses ist etwa viermal
so groß aber es funktioniert
wissenschaft
ich wollte verstehen was im kopf eines
kindes vorgeht wird es beginnt zur
selbstkontrolle fähig zu sein wenn es
durch diese wunderbare verwandlung geht
die ich an meinem eigenen drei töchtern
in kurzen abständen beobachten konnte
das war in den frühen 60er jahren
ich war ein junger professor an der
stanford universität und meine drei
töchterchen waren drei vier und fünf
jahre alt der reihe nach heißen sie
judith rebecca und linda eigentlich ja
mein buch ist im wesentlichen ihnen
gewidmet und dem was ich von ihnen
gelernt habe
indem ich einfach diesen wunderbaren
wandel beobachten konnte der sich in
unseren kindern vollzieht wenn wir sie
genau beobachten vom augenblick der
geburt an bis sie 34 jahre alt sind und
im alter von vier fünf sechs jahren
verändert sich nicht nur ihr verhalten
und ihr verstand es geschehen auch
veränderungen in ihrem gehirn die sie
befähigen impulsen zu widerstehen wenn
sie es wollen um ein fernes ziel ins
auge zu fassen
diese beiden süßigkeiten für später
und sie haben sich selbst unter
kontrolle und thun erstaunliche dinge
damit es für sie leichter wird zum
beispiel wandeln sie die äußerst
schwierige aufgabe des wartens in etwas
um das weniger anstrengend ist
wir schauen uns das gleich an wie das
dann aussieht als sie oder wenn man
kinder in diesen scanner laboratorium
ich weiß nicht so viel davon aber ich
glaube freut würde ja sagen oder sagte
so ein baby ist mal ein bündel von
trieben und schreit und
nicht vielmehr haben sie freud widerlegt
oder stinkt das was er gesagt hat was
freud dazu sagte war sehr interessant
und teils richtig teils falsch freuds
auffassung war dass das kleinkind fähig
wird dem kleineren zu widerstehen und
das größere abzuwarten
sobald es sich eine vorstellung vom
objekt der begierde machen kann
konkret sich ein bild von der mutter
machen kann ein bild als ersatz von ja
das war feuz vorstellung und ich denke
was wir dann in unseren experimenten
untersucht haben hat ein stück weit
darauf bezug genommen aber sie gingen
weiter dass wir haben jetzt
herausgefunden haben ja sehr viel weiter
als dank gab es diese übungsanlage die
wir auch wieder im kindergarten ihrer
töchter wo sie diese experimente gemacht
richtig der grund warum ich mich für das
problem der selbstkontrolle und der
aufgeschobenen belohnung zu
interessieren begann war eine
offensichtliche ahnungslosigkeit mit zug
auf das was in den köpfen meiner kinder
vor sich ging und was diese
veränderungen bewirkt so dass sie fähig
wurden belohnungen aufzuschieben
diese sogenannten marshmallow
experimente die wir mit allen möglichen
dingen durchführten welche sich das
jeweilige kind wünschte drehten sich
darum herauszufinden was im kopf eines
kindes vorgeht was es befähigt von der
impuls steuerung zur selbstkontrolle
überzugehen dass er damals vor 50 jahren
ihre ersten experimente wurden noch
nicht gefehlt aber das ist wiederholt
worden und es gibt auf youtube
millionenfach wahrscheinlich 100
millionen mal angeklickt haben ja werfen
wir einen blick
hier haben wir das zum beispiel hier
sehen wir ein kleines mädchen unter sich
hier schon fünf mal größer als das was
wir brauchten aber dass eine andere
branche gemacht
finden sie nicht so gut aber es geht
auch der test sogar ja jetzt er hat eine
strategie erweist fast hinein sehen sie
jetzt schon welcher mensch einen
erfolgreichen sie hat schon verloren
sobald sie probiert ist sie erledigt
[Musik]
was machte er
nein
er nicht er aber der andere ist ein
erfolgsmensch herrschaft aus kannst
warten oder 102 später und weg verloren
[Musik]
wir sehen die kinder haben ganz
verschiedene strategien
[Musik]
die wollen ja keine eigene mehrheit den
test bestanden
und schwupps
können wir sagen
dazu möchte ich folgendes sagen die
strategien die wir hier gesehen haben
sind nicht annähernd so vielfältig wie
jene die ich in den echten experimenten
sehen konnte und den kinder sind fähig
die schwierige aufgabe des wartens in
eine leichtere umzuwandeln
sie wurden zum beispiel in ihrer
nasenlöchern sie erforschten die ohren
und spielt mit dem was sie zu tage
gefördert hatten sie zu ihre schuhe aus
und spielt mit den zehen als ob es
klaviertasten wären sie sangen sich
selbst keine lieder vor
sie ist es mal home in redwood city die
kinder haben auf die verschiedensten
arten versucht die schwere aufgabe in
eine viel leichtere umzufunktionieren
wir haben dann in experimenten
systematisch studiert welche
vorstellungen vom objekt der begierde
welche mentalen bilder welche strategien
können kinder anwenden um aus dieser
schweren aufgabe
eine leichtere zu machen hatten viel
mehr strategien gefunden als die kinder
in ja dieser film warum war das
experiment nicht so klug gemacht
es war kein echtes experiment es war
eine große demonstration für youtube
aber viele haben ist nach ihnen versucht
wie viele kinder haben überhaupt eine
lösung gefunden 15 minuten mussten die
glaube ich warten wenn sie das 2 15
minuten da haben es geschafft
gegen 30 prozent der kinder schafften
ist die ganze zeit zu wachen weitere 25
prozent läuteten nach weniger als einer
minute und der rest lag irgendwo
dazwischen
man hat nur gewonnen
diese ganzen 15 20 minuten warten kann
es gibt kein gewonnen
es gibt ja gar keinen test die idee vom
test ist später von den medien
geschaffen worden und nicht von der
forschung
es ist ein maß um herauszufinden was für
strategien kinder anwenden und wie lange
sie warten können wir erzählten also
nicht die sekunden die sie waten konnten
aber es ist ein kontinuierliches maß wie
kommt eine aber etwas anderes möchte ich
hervorheben
die beispiele von youtube zeigen die
forschenden wie sie mit zwei stück
zurück komme die unserem falle aber
warteten die kinder mit drei stück also
mit diesen beiden und noch einer
sie hatten somit beim warten den
überblick über das ganze damit sollte
gewährleistet sein dass die kinder
glauben dass es da sein wird weil es
bereits da ist und sie vertrauen können
denn schon vor dem sogenannten mars
mellow experiment forschte in der
karibik in trinidad
da zeigte sich das wichtigste bei der
entscheidung für die spätere belohnung
also die zwei statt das eine zu wählen
ist zu glauben dass man den lohn
wirklich bekommt man ist eigentlich eine
lebensphilosophie haben mit einer einen
zukunfts glauben wenn man der welt
misstraut dann dann ist jedes warten
nutzlos das ist wie bei einer großen
inflation da macht sparen keinen sinn
ohne eine berechenbare anlage in der ich
glauben kann dass sie mir tatsächlich
die beiden geben würde ich sofort dass
eine nehmen aber das bringt mich auf die
frage sie haben diese experimente im
stanford unikaten gemacht das sind alles
kids von sehr klugen zum teil reich in
wohlhabenden leuten die sind vielleicht
sehr optimistisch würde das auch gelten
für kinder die irgendwo in der
aufwachsen dass sie sagen nicht vertraue
auf die zukunft ich bin vollkommen mit
ihnen einverstanden
die kinder von stanford waren eine
solche elitegruppe dass ich mich
wunderte dass wir überhaupt unterschiede
zwischen kindern fanden die einen
soliden hintergrund hatten und die bei
uns alle so gut abschnitten
aus diesem grunde gingen wir in der tat
in die south bronx arbeiten und ich
wechselte 19 83 von stanford an die
columbia universität wo ich den rest
meines lebens verbrachte
und das von der south bronx nur minuten
entfernt ist
dort hatten wir reichlich gelegenheit
vergleichbare experimente durchzuführen
das tun wir immer noch mit
bevölkerungsgruppen die sich grundlegend
von derjenigen in stanford unterscheiden
in dieser elitären gesellschaft von
stanford war ich ja nichts
außergewöhnliches wenn die kinder
einander fragten auf welchem gebiet hat
denn dein de die den nobelpreis bekommen
[Gelächter]
auch dort gab es nur jedes dritte kind
das wirklich schon willens stark war und
die zwei anderen von drei kindern haben
es verpasst
ja ja die verteilung der entscheidungen
in der stanford gruppe war nicht
signifikant anders als in anderen
bevölkerungsgruppen die wir studierten
und die auch andere forscher anderswo
auf der welt studierten das letztlich
wir haben es angeboren bekommen
willensstärke einer von drei yards die
anderen 2 ich glaube einer der
wichtigsten beweggründe mein buch zu
schreiben war eben gerade klar zu machen
dass dies eine falsche auffassung ist
und dass das nicht stimmt wir alle die
kinder haben wissen es gibt sogar
zwischen eineiigen zwillingen starke
unterschiede
und sie treten schon früh zutage
die wichtigsten erkenntnisse aus den
marshmallow experimenten und aus den 50
jahren arbeit seit deren beginn sind die
dass die strategien zur entwicklung von
willenskraft und selbstkontrolle gelehrt
und gelernt werden können und zwar
leichter als man lange angenommen hat
das ist eine gute nachricht dann
verfällt man nicht in diesen biologismus
und determinismus aber am start ist auch
ungerecht das konzept über das zu
sprechen und das zu verstehen äußerst
schwierig ist ist das konzept der
interaktion
es besagt dass es sehr wohl genetische
einflüsse gibt aber was mit diesen
genetischen einflüssen geschieht und wie
sie sich auswirken welche teile der dna
aktiviert werden und welche nicht hängt
nicht nur von den biologischen und
physischen gegebenheiten ab sondern sehr
auch davon was wir tun wie wir denken
wie wir die welt auffassen und wie wir
uns selbst wahrnehmen es gibt also eine
interaktion zwischen unseren genetischen
gegebenheiten und dem was wir tun und
was das leben mit uns macht das ist sehr
komplex aber es bringt uns eine
hoffnungsvolle optimistische botschaft
nämlich unabhängig davon wie gut oder
schlecht wie ursprünglich ausgestattet
sind wir sind nicht die gefangenen
unserer dna
unser schicksal liegt nicht in den
marsch - das heißt die kritiker die es
gab die sie soeben als der termin ist
ihm geschmeckt haben die haben unrecht
das genauso sehen wir haben unrecht ja
ich erlaube mir jetzt auch wieder mit
einem start psychologen ein bisschen
psychologisch ein bisschen
psychoanalytisch zu werden um ihr
eigenes leben kurz auf den radar zu
nehmen so den familienroman
im sinn von freude ein bisschen zu
beleuchten man kann sagen ihre kindheit
hat stattgefunden in einer szenerie wie
1930 geboren die nazis dominieren alles
die triumph märsche auf den straßen für
eine jüdische familie
das war ein schlechter start nämlich an
ins leben
das war eine schreckliche situation als
achtjähriges kind da war ich in der
schule ich bin in der ersten reihe
gesessen und zwei tage später war ich in
der letzten reihe und am nächsten tag
bin ich gestanden und am nächsten tag
war ich ausgeschlossen und die schule
war vorbei für mich als ich das gelesen
habe
über ihre kindheit habe ich mir gesagt
wenn ich das so erlebt hätte könnte ich
überhaupt je wieder vertrauen in die
welt sind haben wir nicht fast
jahrzehntelang eine wut auf eine
ungerechte welt wo alles falsch ist es
ist eine ungerechte welt das habe ich
sicher so empfunden
doch das ist wohl die realität der welt
waren als englands dotiert jetzt aber
als kind haben sie schon rational gesagt
wir sind jetzt halt anders und wir
werden schlecht behandelt oder einfach
zweifelt nein überhaupt nicht
verzweifelt als kind für mich war das
und ich muss jetzt von deutsch zu
englisch gehen zurück aber für mich als
kind war das wichtigste dass erich i
have to ich muss koste es was es wolle
die situation verändere ich damit meine
ich
wir kamen vom glück begünstigt nach
amerika wir schafften es auszureißen ich
will mich nicht in einzelheiten
verlieren
nach dem ganz schlimme dinge passiert
waren also ich muss ihnen sagen als ich
im buch von der szene gelesen habe wie
ihr vater gedemütigt wurde das hat mich
geschockt das
angedacht das sind die dinge wenn man
sagt so darf die welt nicht sein er
wurde irgendwie durch die straßen
getrieben
ja eigentlich war es noch schlimmer als
ich es beschrieben habe er hat die
kinderlähmung gehabt und konnte selbst
am stock nur mühsam gehen
man hatte ihm aber seinen stock und die
orthopädischen schuhe weggenommen und so
humpelte er durch die straßen im pyjama
zusammen mit anderen juden
es war eine demütigung parade für ein
achtjähriges kind schwer mitanzusehen
[Musik]
ich frage noch einmal geht man nicht
kaputt dann sowas als kind und als das
wäre sicher eine möglichkeit aber mir
ist das nicht passiert
wer viel mehr kaputt gegangen ist war
mein vater er hat sich nie mehr davon
richtig erholt aber meinen schluss war
in der welt etwas zu verändern etwas zu
tun dass wenigstens als stimme dagegen
gehört würde
beatrice topos ergänzte und dann konnte
ihre familie fliehen nach amerika aber
es wurde nicht die ankunft im paradies
im gelobten land überhaupt nicht gern
kommt dem paradies die straßen waren
nicht von gold gemacht es war sehr
interessant und es hat meine
überlegungen zum thema persönlichkeit
beeinflusst etwa die tatsache dass
menschen sich verändern können mein
vater zum beispiel veränderte sich er
wurde depressiv und zerfiel
während meine mutter einzelne hausfrau
die nichts tat als ich von zeit zu zeit
aufzuregen
zur heldin der familie wurde arbeiten
annahm und die familie über die runden
brachte erkenntnisse die ich daraus
gewann war dass menschen sich verändern
können und es auch tun wenn die umstände
es erfordern
die familie war nicht auf rosen gebettet
was haben ihre eltern ein bisschen
geschenkt ein geschäft ein billig
geschäft betrieben in burg linn haben
wir ein ladengeschäft eröffnet
ich habe auch mitgearbeitet es war ein 5
cent 10 cent laden ein kleiner volvos
laden
das meiste war für fünf oder zehn cent
zu haben
wir verkauften alles mögliche für den
haushalt und dann war ich auch bewegt
als ich gelesen habe
sie ging dann doch zur schule natürlich
und haben ihren weg in amerika
buchstaben knie und begonnen oder im
kinderland picasa großer sorge weil ich
schon fast neun jahre alt war und zum
englischlernen in einen kindergarten
gesteckt wurde
so versuchte ich mich so klein wie
möglich zu machen um nicht aus der
gruppe hervor zu stechen
dann sind sie auf den knien darum gehen
ein bisschen versucht hier häufig
stammen jedoch einmal jetzt sind sie man
darf das sagen weil man kann es gar
nicht glauben
mit 85 ein führender forscher immer noch
auf der welt fröhlich gezeigt und alles
was man sich wünschen könnte und haben
so auf den knien angefangen ist es nicht
doch erstaunlich dass ein kind das packt
ich finde schon dass es eine
interessante geschichte ist aber so
einmalig ist sie gar nicht diese
geschichte ereignet sich immer wieder
und ich begegne ihr auch heute noch bei
meiner arbeit in der south bronx die
kinder die um jahre jünger staaten als
ich damals mit meinen acht jahren
sie fangen buchstäblich mit nichts an
nicht mit dem glücklichen hintergrund
den ich hatte bis ich acht jahre alt war
sie kommen aus zerrütteten familien aus
schwierigen verhältnissen aus dem was
wir heute toxischen stress nennen
sie kommen aus verhältnissen die
wirklich chaotisch unberechenbar und
gefährlich sind wenn dieses glück haben
ein los zu gewinnen um eine bestimmte
schule die channel school zu besuchen
die genau darauf ausgelegt ist solche
kinder zu erfassen und ihnen zu helfen
dann können sie ein erfolgreiches leben
beginnen
und also wird es auch bei sie verlost
wird gehen darf und wer nicht
es geschieht mittels einer lotterie weil
da nicht genug plätze sind ja es ist
eine große tragödie die sich permanent
ereignet und nicht nur in der south
bronx weil die schere zwischen arm und
reich in den usa ständig größer wird und
immer mehr menschen aus dem sozialen
netz fallen geschieht diese tragödie die
nicht sein müsste was umso trauriger ist
denn wenn man diesen kindern eine
möglichkeit gibt den anschluss zu finden
und zu lernen
verwandeln sie sich für eine der wahren
begebenheiten im buch ist die von george
einem jungen burschen dessen eltern als
er neun war
die lotterie für die pendler school
gewannen eine kipp school das heißt mit
dem sogenannten knowledge ist power
programm
george ist daran sein studium an der
yale-universität abzuschließen ist es
wieder etwa einer von dreien schafft es
wäre unsinnig zu versuchen eine
prozentzahl zu nennen aber es gibt viele
kinder die es schaffen und noch viele
mehr die es schaffen könnten wenn das
schulsystem und die unterstützungs
einrichtung besser wären
das ist dann auch ein politischer kampf
den sie gerne führen muss ich sagen man
müsste natürlich viel mehr kinder und
diese chance geben ich frage nochmal
nach ihrem weg dann in der bildung
ganz oben gekommen professor an den
besten universitäten
warum wollten sie psychologe werben
sicher hat die tatsache dass freud nicht
weit vom zweiten bezirk entfernt wurde
wo ich aufwuchs ihren eindruck
hinterlassen das gibt mir im gedächtnis
wie so vieles andere aus meiner frühen
kindheit um mir das college leisten zu
können musste ich alle möglichen jobs an
unter anderem arbeitete ich auch als
angelernter sozialarbeiter mit sehr
kleinen kindern die aus fürchterlich
benachteiligten verhältnissen stammten
dabei realisierte ich dass das was ich
in der schule gelernt hatte mich in
keiner weise befähigte diesen kinder zu
helfen
das motivierte mich der frage
nachzugehen welches sind die
eigenschaften die zum erfolg befähigen
welches sind die psychologischen
eigenschaften die kleine kinder
befähigen unter ungünstigen bedingungen
zu leben und sich in der welt zu
behaupten was das buch über die
marshmallow tests zeigt ist die
geschichte von der suche und den
erkenntnissen in der hirnforschung und
in meiner eigenen arbeit
diese bieten eine hervorragende
möglichkeit eine neue andere
philosophischer sicht zu gewinnen auf
das was den menschen ausmacht und wozu
er fähig ist wenn und da gibt es einige
sehr wichtige wenn in der saison per
import and export was diese bands sind
davon handelte stufen das ist seine
botschaft und der messe
ich höre immer klarer heraus die
vorwürfe gewisser kritiker der
marshmallow test würde beweisen es gibt
erfolgstypen die warten können kalte
dusche und helden ins b und weicheier
beide fressen nichts könnte falscher
sein das nicht könnten wir ja das genau
der fall
was ich besonders aufregend finde ist
das das geheimnis nun gelüftet ist
wir haben eine viel klarere vorstellung
davon was die eigenschaften die
bedingungen und die verschiedenen
denkweisen sind welche sich die menschen
aneignen können
damit erweitern sie ihre
handlungsoptionen und sie gewinnen das
wichtigste nämlich das bewusstsein für
das handeln das bewusstsein
ich kann das ich kann etwas verändern
findet es faszinierend und beim lesen
des buches habe ich nur einen moment
gezweifelt ob wir sie wieder ausladen
sollten als sie sehr wahrhaftig
berichten dass sie ein starker raucher
waren der drei päckchen zigaretten dann
eine zigarette an die pfeife geraucht
hat
professor michael raucht unter der
dusche und schreibt bücher man muss den
willen kontrollieren kann und sie haben
es jahrelang fast jahrzehnte nicht
geschafft habe ich gesagt ist er einer
der die heime gesagt hat was er predigt
[Gelächter]
ich habe eine enthüllungs kurve macht
das entscheidende dabei ist
festzustellen dass man ein problem hat
ich habe jahrelang drauflos geraucht und
gedacht dass all dies zu einem mann von
welt gehört das änderte sich als ich
durch die säle der medizinischen
fakultät von stanford ging und sah wie
ein mann auf einer transport liege durch
den saal gefahren wurde so kahl
geschoren wie ich aber mit kleinen
grünen markierungen über den ganzen
schädel und auf der nackten brust
ich fragte die pflegerin was los sei und
sie sagte das sind die punkte für die
bestrahlung
hat metastasierenden lungenkrebs dieses
bild hat etwas wichtiges bei mir
ausgelöst
ich konnte es nicht vergessen und es hat
bewirkt dass sie vermeintlich
aufgeschobenen folgen die wir getrost
vergessen können plötzlich eine
aktualität bekam dass sie lebendig und
heiß wurden
es ist wichtig festzustellen dass unser
gehirn ein heißes und ein kühles system
besitzt das heiße system ist das
limbische das ursprüngliche dass wir von
beginn weg das kühlsystem sitzt im
stirnhirn lassen
das heiße system will die mars mellow
und die plätzchen sofort oder es will
rauchen das kühlsystem kann sich über
die späteren folgen rechenschaft ablegen
es geht also immer darum mit dem kühlen
system die impulse des heißen systems
unter kontrolle zu bringen und bei ihm
war das also mit diesem schockierenden
bild von einem menschen der wirklich
jetzt da bestrahlt wurde
das wird viele interessieren die uns
zuschauen weil in der schweiz auch
glaube ich sind so 28 bis 30 prozent
raucherinnen und raucher ist das fast
schon ein tipp den man geben kann geht
in so ein spital wo bestrahlten und
schaut euch das an oder mal so eine
richtig üble offen ich finde dass jeder
erfahrung selbst durch ein rollenspiel
durch die vorstellung zum beispiel durch
ein programm in dem der schwere raucher
ein gespräch mit dem arzt spielt und
dieser die röntgenbilder aus dem
umschlag nimmt und sagt das comeback
schlechte nachrichten für sie die
aktivierung der bilder mit denen wir
normalerweise nicht konfrontiert werden
möchten ist unumgänglich wenn wir die
zukunft in betracht ziehen wollen das
ist viel schwieriger als diesen
süßigkeiten zu widerstehen
wir haben 130 kommt gleich seither haben
sie keine zigarette mehr angefasst
angezündet als genauso ist es keine
einzige
nein keine einzige weil ich aber auch
gewusst dass wenn ich eine war auch dann
brauche ich viel mehr sie haben 30
minuten durchgehalten wenn sie wollen
jetzt darum sind sie ein bekannter
vorschlag worden weil sie diese diesen
belohnungs aufschub so gut dass man das
bild von der zukunft lebendig vor augen
hat so dass es zur gegenwart wird spielt
eine entscheidende rolle bei der
selbstkontrolle
jetzt leuchtet mir das sehr ein
natürlich und wenn es um leben und tod
geht auch würden die meisten vielleicht
reagieren sagen eigentlich will nicht
früh sterben nicht wie lange leben
trotzdem könnte man sagen hinter den
erkenntnissen verbirgt sich dann auch
diese westliche philosophie sei klug der
protestantismus hat das immer empfohlen
fleißig sein ora et labora arbeite spare
so ist kapitalismus auch dann richtig
fahrt aufgenommen man könnte jetzt sagen
es gibt aber eine ganz andere
lebensphilosophie die kp die npd-plakate
verlieren nutze den tag flüge dem tag da
gibt es philosophie bücher voll ich habe
einen kleinen filmausschnitt mitgebracht
damit wir also in diese carpe diem
stimmung kommen besonders schön wird
diese philosophie von carpe diem java
gestellt da im film dead poets society
das sehen wo der lehrer den neuen
schülern klar macht wie wichtig es ist
dass hier und jetzt nicht zu verpassen
professor michael verrät ihr tolles buch
nicht ein bisschen die carpe diem
philosophie nennt es uns nicht den mut
zu sagen ich sage was ich mache es
einfach jetzt kappe gm ist enorm wichtig
als sind sie nicht dagegen überhaupt
nicht nur live
ein leben in dem wir nicht den tag
pflücken in dem wir keine freude haben
indem wir dieses zeug nicht essen
der tag ist noch nicht vorüber ich
hinter ein leben ohne freude ohne genuss
ohne positive gefühle ist nicht
lebenswert der entscheidende punkt bei
der fähigkeit zur selbstkontrolle ist
dass sie eben eine fähigkeit ist die
braucht man ja nicht die ganze zeit
anzuwenden verfehlt siege doch dann
gelingt auch das carpe diem nicht wenn
man nämlich die fähigkeit zur
selbstkontrolle nicht hat dann kann man
auch keine zukunftspläne machen keine
ziele anvisieren
den sinn des lebens nicht finden und
nicht zielstrebig handeln indem man
beispielsweise zur schule geht der ritt
diese typen im film wären ohne fähigkeit
zur selbstkontrolle nicht einmal zur
schule gegangen sind sie erst einmal in
der schule und sind fähig zur
selbstkontrolle haben sie alle
wahlmöglichkeiten die uns das leben
bietet nämlich wenn wir den tag ergreife
und waren wir auf die zukunft hin
arbeiten
die kernaussage meines buches und die
erkenntnis unserer forschung ist dass
die selbstkontrolle den menschen die
wahlmöglichkeit gibt was diese damit an
machen ist ihre sache
selbstkontrolle gibt uns die freiheit
auf die marshmallows zu warten damit wir
die marshmallows unter kontrolle haben
und nicht sie uns
kontrovers controllers das ist
interessant also wir haben die freiheit
aber das heißt nicht wir sollen über
ängstliche über strukturierte zauderer
werden was 1968 die studenten in paris
wohnen ja ja professor ist auch in paris
an die wände gesprüht haben
suite alles wollen wir jetzt wollen wir
was in manchmal ist das eine gute idee
hat sind sie auch der typ da manchmal
gesagt habt jetzt packe ich zu jetzt
schlafen
durchaus ein leben ohne spontaneität und
ohne dass man den tag buchstäblich pakt
ist vielleicht ein leben voller
kompetenzen aber ohne freude und
vergnügen entscheidungen zwischen warten
und nicht warten zwischen wofür arbeiten
und wofür nicht das sind die
herausforderungen des lebens
aber worum es in dieser forschung zum
thema der sogenannten handlungs
kontrolle oder handlungs funktion
wirklich geht ist die freiheit selbst zu
entscheiden und nicht die opfer unserer
biografie oder unserer biologie zu sein
so barbara grofe victims oberbayern
es gibt ja leute die finden professoren
und dann vielleicht professoren der
elite-universitäten dieser welt seinen
entschuldigen eierköpfe leute in einem
elfenbeinturm die das leben vor allem
beobachten kinder in ein labor stecken
statt richtig am leben teilzunehmen hat
das was hätten sie auch noch
draufgängerischer sein können oder als
professor das ist auch für sie das volle
leben
ich bin sehr glücklich darüber dass ich
noch vor meiner wissenschaftlichen
forschungsarbeit in klinischer
psychologie praktizieren konnte darin
war ich ursprünglich auch ausgebildet
worden und ich hatte reichlich einblick
in das ausmaß der tragödien in unserer
welt in der realen welt gelobte ich in
meiner eigenen forschung nur probleme
aufzugreifen die konkret genug sind dass
sie die alltäglichen verwerfungen und
freuden unseres lebens ok also wegen der
verspäteten
ausstieg aus dem rauchen habe ich sie
nicht ausgeladen und sie haben nicht
überzeugt das war gar nicht so schlimm
dann habe ich ein ich wollte sie nicht
ausladen aber ich habe gründe gesucht
die vielleicht ihre theorie doch
widerlegen können und dann bin ich auf
die problematik der querschläger
gekommen menschen die gleichzeitig total
erfolgreich sind zu den erfolgreichsten
menschen auf dem planeten gehören und
diese selbstkontrolle überhaupt nicht
beherrschen ich habe in der einleitung
dominique strauss-kahn erwähnt in paris
dort spricht man auch von ihm einer der
präsident wäre jetzt diese europäischen
großen nation frankreich und jetzt vor
gericht ist als einer der wir sagen was
in der schweiz wie eine wildsau üble
feste gefeiert hat oder noch besser das
beispiel bill clinton der sich als er
präsident von einer jungen frau die wir
hier so monica lewinsky so aus der ruhe
bringen ließ das sage ich mal
das ist ihm fast das amt gekostet hätte
und dann ist ein großer wortkünstler was
ist eine 6 uhr löschen aber wenn man
weiß was unter dem schreibtisch im
oberlauf ist wahrscheinlich zugegangen
ist wahres gelogen und damals aus dieser
skandal ausbrach haben die journalisten
auch sie angerufen und gefragt wie kann
das sein ja die antwort die ich den
journalisten gab und was ich im buch
diskutiere war
wenn wir genau hinsehen so sind wir ja
alle nicht wirklich so wie wir uns
selbst darstellen
wir reden über uns selbst als wären wir
gewissenhafte menschen voller
selbstkontrolle und als gäbe es
gewissenlose menschen ohne kontrolle
tatsächlich aber wenn wir genau
hinschauen gibt es dunkle punkte in
jedermanns leben
die frage in bezug auf präsident clinton
war kann man dem mann der im epizentrum
der macht im weißen haus sitzt und
weltweit wichtige entscheidungen trifft
vertrauen angesichts dessen was er an
eben diesem ort sonst noch getan hat und
eine antwort an die journalistin war
dass beide dinge voneinander abgekoppelt
sind
derselbe bill clinton der ein stipendium
gewonnen an der yale-universität in
recht doktoriert hatte und präsident der
vereinigten staaten geworden war
derselbe hatte auch andere seiten der
arzt junkfood war übergewichtig von den
vielen hamburgers und er hatte die
probleme die wir eben gesehen haben war
das ganze leben lang ein wo man ja dann
gibt es noch die beispiele strauss kahn
oder tiger woods beim sport wir geben
täglich vor von den schlagzeilen
sortiert zu sein wenn schon wieder eine
weitere person dunkle flecken in ihrer
biografie aufweist
aber jedes mal wenn wir in den spiegel
schauen müssen wir uns eingestehen dass
wir unsere eigenen dunklen flecken haben
der erste schritt beim versuch
herauszufinden was man in bezug auf die
selbstkontrolle unternehmen müsste ist
zu überlegen wo liegen möglicherweise
die dunklen flecken in meinem leben und
wie kann ich sie angehen
hatten sich doch vielleicht überlegen
sollen seine ganze karriere hindurch gab
es wieder die
skandale paul jones es gab viele das
hätte ihn die karriere kosten konnten
kann bevor er am schreibtisch des open
office sitzt ist er ja so klug und so
kontrolliert sonst ist er ist manchmal
der trieb einfach stärker
aber das wichtigste aus dieser
erkenntnis ist dass die gleiche person
die auf dem ein gebiet höchst
gewissenhaft ist auf einem anderen
gebiet genau das gegenteil sein kann
darin erkennen wir die wahrheit darüber
wie wir geschaffen sind und wer wir sind
ohne diese fähigkeit zur selbstkontrolle
kann man nicht präsident werden
doch mit der fähigkeit zur
selbstkontrolle ist alles möglich und
eine fülle von ergebnissen können
herauskommt chaos komplett
es kann doch kein zufall sein dass bei
mächtigen leuten drei politikern am
spitzenplatz ihre gesellschaft oft 6 die
frage ist die französischen könige
hatten offiziell mätressen ist sex und
macht aus psychologischer sicht etwas
das dann oder daran dass der mächtige
schnell haben sagte ich ich nominiere
die welt dann stehen wir andere menschen
im fachjargon heißt ja der satz der dies
zu erklären versucht mit der macht
kommen auch die berechtigung theorien im
augenblick da man zu dieser art ruhm
gelangt ist als sheen bekommt man das
gefühl man habe gewisse vorrechte und an
die eigenen schwächen denkt man gar
nicht mehr wenn ein mensch alle anderen
müssen sie für politiker noch ein
kapitel dazu schreiben
es hat glaube ich schon seinen platz
bekommen
die müssen doppelt checken ob sie's
nicht die versuchungen denen sie
ausgesetzt sind nehmen zu
das hatte ich auch
und damit auch die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass sie ein gefühl von ich kann alles
haben was ich will bekommen
also die gelegenheiten werden auch mehr
wenn man ein machtmensch oder ein
weltstar ist für akademiker auch ein
bisschen ich meinen sie sind somit
daniel kahneman wahrscheinlich beiden
berühmtesten psychologen der welt hat
man manchmal mühe bescheiden zu bleiben
wenn die verlockungen kommen einfängt
die versuchungen lauern überall und
niemand ist davor gefeit
die zahl der heiligen ist wahrscheinlich
viel geringer als die zahl der allzu
menschlich eine der traurigsten
tatsachen in der wissenschaft sind nicht
die sex geschichten über wissenschaftler
sondern die skandale wegen betrugs oder
wegen datenfälschung im
wissenschaftsbetrieb sind die
versuchungen enorm die wirkung dessen
was man tut zu steigern
und ich muss betonen dass die
korrelation zwischen der dauer des
wartens auf dem marsch melos und dem
erfolg im leben nicht so groß ist das
sind kleine korrelationen die
statistisch zwar signifikant sind aber
sie manifestieren sich sicher nicht mit
solchen übertreibungen
diese kommen nur von leuten welche die
daten falsch interpretieren und nicht
von den daten selbst nicht reine
qualität es ist korrelation und pro
mobilität
trotzdem gibt es leute die denken in
verschiedenen kulturen sind ist die
neigung
hart und entschieden und erfolgreich zu
sein größer als in anderen ich fand
interessant
die stelle wo sie beschreiben auftritte
hat hatten sie gleichzeitig zwei
community zwei kulturellen hintergründen
in der nähe nämlich afrikaner von denen
man sagt 'die leben das ist siehst du ja
das glück der party kümmert sich nicht
um sorgen und in der geschäftsleute und
so die ganze demonstrieren aufbauen nur
immer arbeiten ist da was dran
verschiedene kulturen sind verschiedene
fleißig die einen sind ameisen und die
anderen wie sie im buch schreiben v der
schrecken sicher gibt es kulturelle
unterschiede darin wie anstrengungen
gemacht werden und wofür
doch ich möchte zum beispiel mit dem
blick auf meine arbeit in der karibik
noch einmal betonen dass die gleiche
gruppe von menschen die angeblich nicht
die zukunft in betracht ziehen sondern
spontan und impulsiv sind arbeiten jedes
jahr auf eine noch fern liegende
belohnung hin wenn sie sich auf den
karneval vorbereiten sie sind ein
fantastisches beispiel von
selbstkontrolle
sie arbeiten wie die tiere um ihre
fabelhaften kostüme fertig zu stellen
sie sind perfekt organisiert sie starten
ihre motivwagen auf pompöse sste aus auf
die situation darauf an und dann ist es
nicht vorbestimmt genau es gibt in jeder
kultur sehr schöne beispiele dafür wo
sie den schwerpunkt ihrer bemühungen
setzt vielleicht sind das nicht
sparanstrengungen im hinblick auf den
ruhestand vielleicht sind es ganz andere
dinge selbstkontrolle und werte sind
verschiedene belange die ganze
menschheit das ist halt der kondition
schon seit dem paradies sind wir als
menschen der versuchung ausgesetzt
könnte man eigentlich sagen da apfel den
eva im paradies dann packt das ist
gottes marshmallow für eva ja durchaus
und wenn die sich nur ein bisschen zeit
genommen hätten mein buch zu lesen
glaube ich hätte es anders herauskommen
könnte
[Gelächter]
publiziert worden
ok zu spät ist leider aber kann man wenn
man schon nicht mehr paradies und
probleme hat mit der verführung und so
man kann lernen das ist ihre bekannte
sind muskel trainieren einfach ihr buch
lesen und dann ich glaube das
entscheidende ist
ich gebe ihnen ein beispiel aus der
forschung
da war ein kleines mädchen das ich nie
vergessen werde und dass ich erwähne sie
schaffte es nicht mehr als ein paar
sekunden auf die plätzchen zu war vor
sie war wie diese kinder im film da
schlug ich ihr im laufe des experiments
vor du kannst dir ja vorstellen dass die
plätzchen gar nicht wirklich da sind
sondern dass das nur ein bild davon isst
du weißt doch was ein bild ist das kind
sagte ja das ist etwas mit einem rahmen
drumherum
also gut sagte ich während du wartest
und dir vorstellst es sei ein bild setzt
du in deinem kopf einfach einen rahmen
drumherum
damit konnte sie 15 minuten macht da
fragte ich sie wie kommt es dass du 15
minuten warten konntest wo du vorher
gleicht die glocke geläutet hast sie
sagte man kann ein bild nicht essen und
es stimmt wenn man fähig ist zu
abstrahieren das ding mental zu
transformieren hätten sie mir nicht
gesagt dass diese dinger glutenfrei sind
hätte ich kein problem gehabt zu wahren
weil ich ja kein gift es
etwas neue etikett ihren sich
eingestehen dass raucher nicht diese
harmlose luxus ist den ich mir als
uni-professor herausnehmen darf wie
damals in den 60er jahren sondern dass
ich gebraucht
normalerweise wollen sich die menschen
ja nicht selbst vergiften und mit dem
gluten ist es dasselbe leute die gluten
nicht vertragen essen kein gluten sobald
sie feststellen dass es giftig ist in
guten monster release des preußen wollte
michelle sie haben alles erreicht was
man einfach erleben bietet den
nobelpreis gibt's nicht bei den
psychologen nur bei den ökonomen kann
den kann man bekommen hat gibt es dinge
die sie noch aufschieben sie arbeiten
jetzt noch sie sind topfit 85 und hören
nicht auf mitarbeiten müssen sie da noch
was lernen sie haben ja einen optimalen
können sie nicht aussteigen
ich habe eine heimliche seite ich habe
mein leben lang gemalt obwohl ich nie
genug zeit dafür hatte also ist der plan
für mein leben in der zeit die mir noch
bleibt dass man ein des life ball ist
malen aber also sie sind aus lust nicht
ausgestiegen oder aus dieser
selbstkontrolle weil sie denken ich muss
zuerst noch ein bisschen arbeiten bis
ich bin von 90 bis ich dann ein bisschen
ich glaube ich darf sogar heute man ja
aber sie machen es schon daneben ja ja
ich habe einen studio aber es ist nicht
dass sie nicht aussteigen konnten arbeit
ihre arbeit ist ihre ihre lust ihre
erfüllung gar nicht schwer zu arbeiten
weil das ist wirklich meine lust und das
wollen sie auch noch ein bisschen mehr
zu behindern nein nein da ist das für
euch langsam auf wir können das kampf-
und weise mit dieser lust und und dieser
leichtfüßigkeit hier sich bewegen auf
diesen feldern
ich weiß jetzt ein bisschen zusammen
machen also ihre botschaft ist eine eine
botschaft der freiheit man kann lernen
man kann es gestalten und dann schreiben
sie im buch man kann mit ihrem
denkansatz eigentlich die ganz neu
definieren
wie haben sie nach all diesen 50 jahren
studien descartes neu definieren wie der
wichtige satz mit dem uns die karte in
erinnerung geblieben ist heißt ich denke
also bin ich
wer vorher doch im vergangenen halben
jahrhundert haben wir in der hirn- und
verhaltensforschung entdeckt dass wir
das denken verändern können
und weil wir das denken verändern können
können wir verändern wer wir sind was
wir tun und was wir für walter
herzlichen dank das war faszinierend sie
sind mein neuer held in sachen
versuchung und verführung und
selbstkontrolle bis jetzt hat sich
ausgeweitet allem kann ich wieder stehen
nur ja nicht mit ihnen gibt es eine
bessere lösung herzlichen dank für das
gespräch
nächsten sonntag spricht dann meine
kollegin barbara bleisch mit einem
soziologen mit dem kapitalismus kritiker
harald welzer über freiheit die hält er
nämlich für ziemlich bedanke mich
herzlich fürs zuschauen
und jetzt
[Musik]